symphonie en couleurs maintenant pour le
carnaval de cayenne qui se déroule
actuellement pascal richard et bernard
charles on en revienne le carnaval à
cayenne c'est avant tout ça de l'huile
du charbon de bois pile est une mixture
infecte dont les garçons et les filles
s'enduisent tes pieds à la tête
un rituel chaque dimanche on recommence
et pendant toute l'époque du carnaval
on les appelle les [ __ ] marrons
allusion aux anciens esclaves noirs qui
avaient alors trouvé refuge en guyane
fond la police du carnaval c'est à dire
qu' il ya des milliers de gens qui
descendent dans les rues de cayenne et
les neg marrons ben on n'aime pas
vraiment se frotter à eux parce que
c'est pas s p prêts très accueillants on
n'a pas du tout envie de salir les
costumes qu'on a préparé pour les
défilés du carnaval
alors basse et la police quoi c'est
mieux qu'une matraques ont forment le
cercle et on se masse autour des des
gens qui font les filets pour éviter que
ça déborde que ça aille dans les rues
mme saloua palais que ça suive bien le
parcours prévu
ouais
voilà quoi ces heurts la police du
carnaval entre en action
la fête peut commencer
fête des couleurs et des musiques
cayenne c'est déjà l'amérique du sud
ici tout est permis et tout le monde
participe
carnaval populaire tous les week-ends de
l'épiphanie au mercredi des cendres ce
sont dix à quinze mille personnes qui
vont descendre dans les rues pendant
deux mois et demi la guyane est temps
carnaval c'est très bien ses cadres
qu'est ce qui vous plaît notamment tout
août et bien savoir le carnaval c'est
très bien beaucoup de monde c'est
charmant
voilà par rapport à ses illustres rivaux
le carnaval de cayenne n'a pas de
complexe cultivant au contraire ces
différences et les habits souffre
tournée va s'humaniser bien et s'est
senti bien de vie ils sont bien bien
mais de la samba il y en a aussi
rassurez vous il est vrai qu'ici le
brésil est à moins de 100 km
dernière particularité de ce carnaval du
bout du monde le vide et en fin d'après
midi tout le monde se retrouve sur la
place des palmistes pour une immense
transe collective
la fatigue et le rhum et dans la danse
n'est alors plus que gigantesque
bousculade
on dit souvent que c'est unique au monde
je crois qu'on trouve pas ça aux
antilles
quant au carnaval est finie on pense on
regarde le calendrier et on pense au
calendrier de carnaval de lin de l'année
d'après et ce qui se passe le week-end
pour les dancings et les défilés il faut
il n'y a pas trop de la semaine pour ce
pour s'en remettre après une fête unique
décidément même en amérique du sud